[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute eine
erfrischende himbeer torte ich hab nicht
mal gescrollt auf einem kanal umgesehen
da ist einfach keine reine hubert orte
und deswegen habe ich ja was muss jetzt
ganz schnell nachholen ich habe im
letzten video ein vanille bizkit boden
gebacken meiner meinung nach der
leckerste denn es gibt und dem benutze
ich heute im video das verlinke ich euch
gerne dann könnt ihr euch das schon mal
ansehen ich geh jetzt direkt über
zuzubereiten ihr findet alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben wie immer unten in
der infobox ich starte jetzt mit meinen
himbeeren ihr könnt frische nehmen ihr
könnt aber auch tiefgekühlte nehmen
lassen sie vorher einfach aufbauen und
die werde ich jetzt erwerben damit ich
sie einfach besser pürieren kann und ihr
dürft auch ein bisschen wasser dazugeben
dann biss sich einfacher pürieren lässt
ich halte jetzt auch den herd auf
mittlerer stufe 1 und fange einfach an
das ganze zu pürieren damit ich dann
anschließend passieren kann denn ich für
meinen teil möchte die kleinen stückchen
oder besser gesagt da nicht drin haben
[Musik]
so ich dies jetzt die himbeer massa
einmal zurück in den topf und damit wir
das ganze jetzt ein bisschen fester
kriegen arbeite ich mit speisestärke das
heißt einfach die speisestärke mit
wasser verrühren klümpchen freie
natürlich und dann kommt das in die hier
mehr masse und wird unter ständigem
rühren einmal aufgekocht und das bewegt
einfach dass das ganze dann dk wird
[Musik]
zu den himmel masse ist jetzt eingedeckt
ich überlegt habe ob ich da vielleicht
noch ein bisschen zucker mit rein gebe
weil manchmal sind auch frische
himbeeren recht sauber daher probiere
ich mal ich hoffe dass sich die zunge
verbrennen
schon sauer daher gebe ich da jetzt noch
einen guten esslöffel zucker mit dazu
und lass das so einfach ein bisschen
abkühlen damit es gleich nicht auf die
kalte sahne creme kommt
[Musik]
für die creme wird kalte schlagsahne
zusammen mit sahne fest steif geschlagen
und es funktioniert auch wunderbar wenn
die seine ganz frisch aus dem
kühlschrank kommt dann wird sie nämlich
so fest und ich mache jetzt weiter mit
den restlichen zutaten da gebe ich jetzt
mascarpone magerquark puderzucker und
vanille extrakt in meine schüssel und
anschließend werde ich das auch mit dem
handrührgerät einmal kurz durchrühren
gibt dann seine bis dazu und dann ruhig
wirklich nur noch so lange bis sich
alles miteinander verbunden hat
zum schluss dann nur noch die steif
geschlagene sahne mit einem teig schaber
in zwei bis drei schritten unterheben
und dann ist die creme auch schon fertig
dies an sich so schon sehr sehr lecker
und ich mache das jetzt so dass ich mir
da ein bisschen was wegschnappte für
meine spätere deko dafür einfach einen
spritzbeutel nehmen ich nehm nächste
stern stelle vorne dran aber da könnt
ihr zum beispiel auch nur rosen
teilnehmen und dann einfach rein tun in
die tülle und vorne die spitze
abschneiden
[Musik]
so und jetzt nehme ich mir fünf
esslöffel von der creme und bewahre das
dann im kühlschrank auf denn dann habe
ich halt so die spätere deko direkt
schon mal die creme bereits
jetzt sind ja alle bestandteile für die
torte fertig himbeer pury ist fertig die
sahne krieges fertig und imbissbuden
hatte ich ja wie gesagt schon
vorgebacken jetzt muss er nur noch durch
geteilt werden dann nehmen sie meine
säge und ich habe jetzt mal geguckt er
ist ungefähr fünfeinhalb zentimeter hoch
das heißt ich mache den so 1,7 cm
ungefähr sie müsste zusätzlich so genau
nehmen wie ich aber ich möchte super
gerade haben und daher habe ich mir das
genau ausgemessen und
[Musik]
jetzt die torte einfach schichten ich
nehme hier eine servierplatten legt das
schon mal den ersten boden drauf und
damit ich das alles schön gleichmäßig
bzw gerade verteilen kann dem ich mir zu
hilfe noch mal den toren ringen habe ich
einfach ausgewaschen und klemmen den
einmal drumherum und ich habe mir jetzt
auch zu hilfe ein bisschen was von der
sahne creme und vom himmel pury in
spritzbeutel eingefüllt denn ich habe
vor das gleich aber das seht ihr dann
ich habe vor das gleich so zu verteilen
dass ich die das himmel pury nicht
einfach um darüber verteilen sondern
quasi in kreisen damit man im anschnitt
auch schön aussieht
[Musik]
so die torte ist bis oben hin gefüllt
und eingestrichen die creme ist er jetzt
schon recht fest und daher können wir
auch direkt in voranbringen entfernen
die braucht keine kühlte es sei denn es
hat im hochsommer und es ist ein mega
warm in der küche geben sie ihm eine
backform löser und kann mir dann den
tortenring einmal von der torte
entfernen und dann hebe ich den
tortenring an wert meine torte porto
chelsea hat einteilen ich nehme zwölf
stücke könnt auch 14 nehmen könnt sogar
16 ist nur sehr hohe torte und dann
werde ich sie einfach nur dekorieren
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt meine torte noch mit
frischen himbeeren dekoriert und mit
gefriergetrockneten nehmen wenn ich
finde die machen alles viel schöner ich
persönlich werde sie nicht heute
ansteigen sondern morgen dann gibts auch
den test es ihr könnt sie eigentlich
direkt jetzt schon anschneiden und die
torte herzlich gekühlt im kühlschrank
bis zu vier tage aber wir sehen uns dann
wie gesagt morgen wieder
[Musik]
sid ski sieht heftig ist dass ich heftig
ist
instagram
wir probieren jetzt machen jetzt den
testlauf bist du bereit
also ich hab ich habe lange keine
gebackene torte merkmal wird sommerpause
habe ich das prüfen ich finde die optik
so schön inneren sieht man halt diese
vanille nach vanille diese himberg reise
die ich gezogen habe unique user welche
bereiche dann bricht irgendwann kommata
weg des herbstes und fluffig und sehr
erfrischend von iso matten börse kann
also jetzt kein himmel trocken
hier sehen wir aroma zieht sich durch
den ganzen kuchen ich begann ich mag
nicht gesehen
aber ich finde das sehr sehr ich denke
so ohne alles
richtig lecker also macht auf jeden fall
nahe fühlt sich schwer überhaupt nicht
sehr leicht das passt einfach zu einem
das passt einfach zum sonntagskaffee so
was könnte ich mir auch auf so
einem junggesellen aber
richtig schön heftig schöner sucht kommt
oder so ich wie vor beeindruckt sein
sind also auch so ein café und sowie das
so bestehen würde ich das nicht und
tatsächlich gibt es mehrere cafés die
meine torten anbieten krieg denn auf
instagram immer so eine so eine story an
sich okay das ist ein café und dann
steht da wie von wikis kitchen also
richtig cool auf jeden fall jobs geben
unmöglich unbedingt nachmachen und kommt
dann gern nicht verrückt unterlassungs
feedback und ansonsten wünschen wir euch
noch einen wunderschönen tag bis
zunächst mal auf die spitzenteams
regenbogen
[Musik]